my name is whoops on something I'm from
Tibet born in Tibet and then lady Belle
1959 age of five and came to Nepal first
and then eventually came to India and
sort of it is grow Grove in India and
then eventually came to the United
States and and in 88 and ever since then
are we creating a lot of ancient events
and mandalas of course all the mandalas
attribution but some of the mandalas are
such are all absorb utiful but in some
time it's hard to explain for the
general public who do not have it that
much a background of Buddhism Buddhist
philosophy what I'm showing to here is
an image is called will of life and our
language is called CIPA color the Wheel
of Life which many ways are fascinating
and also me as artists to display this
art in in the schools especially the
schools and kids can understand loud
better and not only just intellectually
understand better but something related
in their life so what are you saying the
willow life in the mandala or in design
the middle of these are three animals
and there are three animals are a snake
rooster and pig three animals are there
they are also chasing to each other
connecting to each other and which means
what is the causes are suffering what
makes us are difficult what makes that
we are so stressful
so each animal means something not the
animal itself but represents something
what we come through day to day basis so
the peak represents the ignorance
lots of due to our emotions special
negative emotions
and difficulties and frustrations and
even killing each other are due to the
ignorance not seeing the true nature of
the reality and unfortunately sometimes
we as a pure teaching in the Buddhism or
Christianity and Judaism Islam and all
of this even though due to how to peace
due to how to create human peace and
happiness but some individual due to the
ignorance used as a killing tool name of
the religion so is a pig the animal
which in the middle symbolized ignorance
to other animals are there too and the
snake represents the anger hatred is a
such a big problem in my life or
anybody's life and today in the past due
to our relationship due to anything that
anger is really are damaging when when
the design this was original was a pig
and the snake that the rooster case are
we really don't know in the original was
a rooster or the pigeon there's a little
different our scholars have our
different art repetitions so that's why
in I draw sin mandala sometime I do as a
rooster sometime I draw as a pigeon do
both okay happy Lord rumors complex and
so the pigeon represents in the pigeon
order a rooster deity zanza agreed
degree agreed who is seen there today in
21st century and so much greed and and
all these a problem in the modern
society damaging for the environment
damaging for many different things
and to truly agree so which I said
earlier in beginning my conversation
these are the three the ignorance and
green and the anchor are the difficulty
one so these are the causes are the
suffering suffering rise from
nothingness suffering rise from due to
something there previously something
happened and because of that and rises
so that's why the Wheel of Life is so
famous in and Buddhist feel and
especially in Tibet or Mongolia in
Bhutan or some of the ancient Buddhist
temples Wheel of Life is in the campus
in a way the monastery or nunnery is the
yoga University so big canvas in Tibet
one monastery is like a 20 or 30
thousand monks who are living there and
steady their debate there that their
home so either in the library or
meditation room summer villa life is so
always they paint in the big wall so
that's the middle of the design of the
real life and the second second design
there and now the from I'm talking about
the middle and the second circle of the
willow live there's a black and white or
day in the night sort of you know is
symbolized more of these three animals
there's a more difficulties less of
those there's more joy
so sometimes we call it as a good karma
and and bad karma and then there's a
third circle is divided into the six
sections are equal to six runs or six
different places we might rip on again
and again and again the six are the
number one is the heaven this is an
unnecessary we are talking heaven as a
other tradition will call ahead
but a little different way and demigods
and the human which we all ritual are
and then animal and then Hungry Ghost
and then he'll run and then the last
ring is called a twelve dependent
origination or depending to each other
one of the most important Buddhist
teachings not only the loving kindness
compassion is are so important but plus
what is that like a revolution urtu me
he he really understood about everything
is interdependent everything is that
depending to each other and so these are
the so many of this our depth of
teachings and simply and explained
through the art and this would be
redoing our many years and thousands and
thousand years in beginning was in India
and then Buddhism came to Tibet around
seventh century and especially around
eight nine ten 11th century really up
Buddhism Louis in Tibet was a so Lolita
sort of sorrow lava you know mix with
their individuals or communities are
life and we'll be doing this alarm wheel
of life in the tango painting their
collet or drawing the image in the wall
but never I'm not sure never done by the
sand but then design is the ancient one
but the material used the sand is a sort
of like a my own own ideas it was up
doing a lot of sand mandalas in the
United States in Canada and many other
places and our reason is because this is
such a unique painting explains as so
much things are were later in our life
but yet but anybody can understood about
his design so that's a really the
meaning of the or the Wheel of Life
you